amphibian goddesses talking vegetables
and nuclear bugs oh my the Shazam comic
books have had quite a bizarre and
colorful history back in the 1940s comic
book stories rarely took up more than 10
pages and cereals were even rarer but
then there was the two-year Marathon
monster Society of evil Arc by
autobinder and CeCe Beck in Captain
Marvel Adventures
22-46 the monster Society is an
interplanetary cabal run by an unseen
Mastermind named Mr mind he has the
entire resources of the Axis powers at
his disposal even Hitler himself happily
takes orders after months of nearly
dying at Mr mind's hands Captain Marvel
finds out that he's actually a
caterpillar with cute little glosses but
this doesn't make him any less of a
threat as Mr Mind turns the Great Wall
of China into a giant shield for the
invading Japanese Army this is a story
so jam-packed that it introduces two
unrelated underground civilizations in
one five page chapter other highlights
include Mr Mind firing so many German
cannons it knocks the Earth out of orbit
and invading Scotland in an
island-shaped Battleship as well as
Captain Marvel on the back of an
unfrozen mammoth Captain Marvel is many
things but we never expected dirty scab
to be part of his resume but in Captain
Marvel and the Revolt of the comics in
Captain Marvel Adventures number 22
that's pretty much exactly what he is
apparently in the Captain Marvel
Universe Comics heroes write and draw
their own stories that becomes a problem
when stand-ins for familiar characters
all walk out including Popeye and Flash
Gordon there's also a version of Batman
who wears a pair of baseball bats and
has an actual Robin for his sidekick
holy headache whatever their grievances
might be Captain Marvel puts them back
to work whether by appealing to their
patriotism or by rescuing his fellow
superheroes from a danger even they
can't handle a mob at the department
store
some of the over-the-top flag waving and
wartime Comics can seem a little
ridiculous but that's not true for every
story some of them are very ridiculous
for instance there's Captain Marvel
visits Portland Oregon or Knighthood
flowers again in Captain Marvel
Adventures number 29 cap is promoting a
scrap metal drive for the war effort
when he meets with a modern day Don
Quixote named Richard chickenheart
chickenheart's obsession with artifacts
has led him to regular spells in which
he thinks he's a medieval Knight to keep
him out of trouble Billy Batson tags
along as his page boy in between turning
into Captain Marvel so that he can
intervene when chicken heart becomes
violent before his mental breakdown
chicken heart is about to melt down his
Priceless collection of unique
historical Treasures to make into guns
and tanks all his troubles turn out to
be the fault of another collector named
Bart black who wants to buy chicken
hearts collection for five thousand
dollars which somehow makes him the bad
guy but nobody seems to realize that all
that money could pay for a lot more
military gear than anyone could ever get
from a couple pounds of armor in Captain
Marvel's Comics natural phenomena are
the work of various Whimsical characters
Captain Marvel enforces the law of
gravity in Captain Marvel Adventures
number 31 adds the Council of gods to
the series improvised Pantheon and they
proceed to repeal you guessed it the law
of gravity predictably this is bad news
back on Earth where Captain Marvel Zips
around the city keeping people from
floating off into space meanwhile some
gangsters take advantage of the
situation by wearing spiked shoes and
towing off a save like a balloon once
he's dispatched them Captain Marvel
chases the problem back to the council
but gets stuck in the waiting room along
with a two-headed toad alien who lets
him know he could be waiting for
eternity fortunately he has connections
since the wizard Shazam used to be on
the council and so he manages to
successfully convince the council to put
the law of gravity back on the books
I can fly Captain Marvel's Adventures
are full of dozens of mad scientists
with elaborate schemes but Dr groon from
Captain Marvel Adventures number 49 goes
above and beyond in the first panel of
Captain Marvel and the unknown killer
grune's medical colleagues are already
Banning him from his brain
transplantation experiments but that
night he seemingly returns to attack one
of the doctors who denounced him before
Captain Marvel intervenes as groon tries
to take out the next man on his Hit List
cap is shocked to discover he's a
gorilla in Disguise you'd think the
hairy arms and legs in the cheap plastic
mask that doesn't even cover his whole
face would have been a tip-off the
gorilla explains that he's the fruit of
groon's experiments and that he killed
the doctor and decided he might as well
kill some more doctors while he's at it
after the ape escapes to kill again
Captain Marvel takes another mask off
him and it turns out that the gorilla is
Dr groon after all cry is foiled Justice
triumphs and we're all left confused
[Music]
in Captain Marvel and his loneliest stay
from Captain Marvel Adventures number 49
Billy Batson over years of broadcast
from The Lone attendant of an iceberg
monitoring station in Greenland
announcing that he's going to quit
before Cabin Fever sets in so Billy
decides that Captain Marvel shall keep
it warm himself as it turns out the
stamina of Atlas doesn't extend to
boredom and it's only a few hours before
cap starts climbing up the walls after
892 games of Solitaire he gets fed up
enough to go hunting for someone to talk
to that leads us to the hilarious image
of Captain Marvel chatting with a
penguin until it eventually covers its
ears with its little flippers the
absurdity escalates as Captain Marvel
decides to train Penguins to dance and a
deer to pull them in a sleigh and also
to dress up a walrus as a clown but then
a polar bear interrupts the proceedings
though after a quick beat down it joins
the circus as well fortunately no one
Witnesses this spectacular breakdown
except the old attendant who happily
takes his job back now that he has the
circus to keep his mind off the Solitude
in Captain Marvel in the land of
surrealism from Captain Marvel
Adventures number 80. Billy covers an
art show by surrealist painter Leonardo
Vince Vince refuses a prize for
imaginative art because he claims he
drew it all from Life nobody believes
him but Billy's at least intrigued
enough to drive with vinge to the goofy
Grotto where all the simple plants and
Eyeball flowers from the paintings
actually do exist cap then has to
intervene when one of the creatures
traps Vince to paint him the Captain
Marvel team returned to this well four
issues later with Captain Marvel and the
surrealist imp this time the land of
surrealism comes to Earth and artistic
inspiration comes from a little
cucumber-headed Imp in a bathrobe he's
bored with all the dull paintings he has
to send down while all the best
surrealist ideas go unused so instead of
sending painter Hans crendler what he
wanted he emerges from crenler's canvas
to inspire more surrealist pain
paintings by turning the real world
surreal first he redecorates crenler's
apartment with a dresser sporting human
hair and ears and tongues for drawer
handles the prank nearly turns deadly
when he twists the highway into a
pretzel but then of course Captain
Marvel's successfully intervenes
what the hell what in Marvel family
number 20 Captain Marvel and the mistake
of Father Time delivers exactly what it
promises when the mystical old man
accidentally leaves his hourglass upside
down during a nap on a cloud back on
Earth Captain Marvel is musing on his
failure to save a crashed pilot because
he was too busy with a house fire this
could have easily been a cheap gimmick
but CC Beck's handling of it seems more
like the work of an avant-garde artist
rather than a superhero adventure most
of Cap's Adventures are as talky as an
episode of Seinfeld but Beck makes the
absurdity of the situation twice as
shocking by playing it totally straight
some scenes like the plane flying
backward play out in Eerie silence it
all adds up to one of the most memorable
stories from any comic of the era
well good luck with all that
Captain Marvel and the dinosaur dilemma
in Captain Marvel Adventures number 123
begins with Billy's boss Sterling Morris
showing up to work with a baby dinosaur
on a leash Dino makes himself a nuisance
in record time tackling Billy and
jumping out the window Billy turns into
Captain Marvel and rescues him and then
he investigates how Sterling found a
dinosaur a couple million years past its
sell by date he finds a pet shop on the
corner offering a special on baby
dinosaurs and traces them to a local
farmer who found the eggs preserved in a
frozen cave for whatever reason he
decided nobody needed to know about the
scientific discovery of the century
except some guy who sells dog food but
that's the least of Captain Marvel's
worries since all the cute little baby
dinos quickly grow up and become a
little too destructive cap pens them in
and finally gets scientists to study
them but that doesn't last long once
Dino breaks clean through the fence cap
eventually decides to load all of the
dinos in a giant bullet-shaped capsule
fly to the Wizard's home on the rock of
Eternity at the Nexus of space and time
and then send them back to their natural
time period in the world of Captain
Marvel even something as abstract as
instincts can make for concrete sparring
partners in Captain Marvel battles the
discarded instincts from Captain Marvel
Adventures number 124 a little old man
discards his bad instincts not through
self-discipline but by locking them in a
chest when his wife throws it out and
Sterling Morris finds it at the flea
market the instincts re-emerge in Smoky
trails that look like ghost versions of
the Seven Dwarves even fairy tale logic
doesn't quite cover just why the little
old man seems to have only discarded
animal instincts to which Captain Marvel
spends most of the story fighting off
the Instinct of hibernation Morris
thinks he can fly once he gets the
Instinct of migration and the Moon being
Instinct makes some poor opera singer
howl like a wolf on live TV plus an
electrician catches the lemming instinct
which makes Lemmings all swim out into
the ocean to die but at least that gives
us the undeniably awesome image of cap
punching a shark so hard that it goes
flying backward pow right nikishi
fortunately Cap's life-saving instinct
is strong enough to beat out the
hibernation Instinct and the little old
man whistles all the instincts back into
the chest Captain Marvel Adventures
number 133 gives us Captain Marvel and
the dog dilemma in which the Title
Character doesn't even appear until a
third of the way through instead the
story follows hard-working groundskeeper
Herman Claude whose duties include
walking his boss's poodle poopsie he
starts thinking about how much easier
poopsie's life is and somehow manages to
whip up an ego exchanging machine right
then and there you don't get much of an
explanation for how this is possible but
at least CC Beck has some fun designing
the device as Herman and poopsie are
wired up to metal caps made from a
coffee container and a dog food can
Captain Marvel gets involved when Billy
spots a grown man barking and chasing a
cat on all fours meanwhile Herman
realizes how half-baked his idea was
when his new owner expects him to eat
dog food and do tricks and then spanks
him when he doesn't after a day of every
indignity a dog can experience Herman
manages to tell Captain Marvel the truth
so cap jams the cans back on Herman and
poopsie's heads and everything goes back
to what passes for normal in these
comics most of these stories come from
the post-war era and this one tackles
the biggest anxiety of the era nuclear
war in Captain Marvel battles the bug
bombs from whiz Comics number 150 Billy
Batson tours an atomic power plant and
quizzes them on their vulnerability to
espionage his guide assures him that
it's airtight except for some ants that
interrupt their lunch alas it turns out
those ants are little spies when the
plant's radar spots the latest of
several unexplained nuclear explosions
in the Amazon Captain Marvel flies down
to investigate and discovers a raiding
party of wasps carrying cute little wasp
sized bombs he also finds an enormous
ant hill and its ruler an enormous ant
it turns out that he grew with the help
of scientific hormones that doesn't
really explain much of anything let
alone why he's wearing what appears to
be a baby blue Christmas cracker crown
and matching boots apparently the
solution to bug war is bug genocide
since cap sets off a chain reaction by
punching a wasp into the atomic pile
that nukes both the wasp and and armies
out of existence
bye
is to fight against the entire world and
that was literally true for Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel battles the world
from Captain Marvel Adventures number
148 ditches the usual third person
omniscient narrator so that Earth can
speak for itself about his annoyance
with humans always digging into his skin
for oil and metal our planet decides
it's had enough and removes all the
clouds to burn Humanity off all the
strength of Hercules can't stand up
against a planet so Captain Marvel has
to lean on the wisdom of Solomon and
outsmart Earth first he drops an ice
asteroid into the atmosphere to restore
the clouds then when Earth starts
knocking over buildings with the Roar of
icebergs grinding together cap plugs
them up with a couple of tons of felt
finally when Earth tries to split the
Americas cap lifts all of South America
like a continent-sized mattress and
flies it back into place before gluing
it together with lava Earth gets ready
to make the fight even meaner when a
giant Comet comes hurtling along but cap
proves that earth needs humans as much
as they need it by annihilating the
comet with a block of plutonium in 1973
DC struck a deal with faucet to produce
new Captain Marvel Comics and a few
years later they bought the characters
outright DC pulled in top talent for
Shazam with CC back returning for the
first few issues along with an A-list
writing staff including Denny O'Neal at
the height of his reinvention of Batman
but the wacky humor of Captain Marvel
Adventures was tough to recapture and a
lot of the 70s Shazam tipped it too far
into plain silliness for instance issue
number 10's invasion of the saladmen is
exactly what it sounds like some
vegetable-shaped aliens crash land on
Earth and freak out all the locals too
much to get any help repairing their
Ship Captain Marvel is the only one
willing to hear them out but he learns
that the repairs are well out of his
price range the solution comes from an
inspired bit of silliness cap and the
vegetable aliens make and release a
movie and then collect the earnings over
the course of what appears to be about
an afternoon and all that silliness is
accompanied by an appropriate blizzard
of terrible puns such as as head lettuce
I am giving the orders
yeah
during Captain Marvel's DC years he
frequently teamed up with his old rivals
Superman and their Adventures rarely got
weirder than Oh Captain My Captain from
Action Comics number 768 caps Sidekicks
Captain Marvel Jr and Mary Marvel show
up in Metropolis to ask for Superman's
help as they think their leaders been
turned into a disembodied chin meanwhile
Junior can't slow down and Mary can only
talk nonsense then a swarm of amphibians
in the shape of one huge frog slices
Mary in half Superman finally realizes
what she's trying to tell him through
all the gibberish and says the magic
word to become Captain Marvel then soups
and his body mate fly into the heart of
the Frog swarm and find the Frog head
Egyptian goddess hekat who is protesting
all the frogs killed in cancer research
there's a lot of weirdness here but also
a lot of sincere love for Captain Marvel
when Superman defends cap after Junior
dismisses him as in also ran he could
just as easily be referring to the
character's neglect in the real world
and when Superman describes Cap's
negotiation with the cut by expressing
how he couldn't possibly think of
anything more ludicrous or more moving
he could be talking about the best
Captain Marvel stories
after Flashpoint rewrote the history of
the DC Universe in 2011 Shazam got as
big an overhaul as anyone for one thing
his name officially became Shazam after
years of everyone calling him that
anyway
well hey there son for another thing the
compact Marvel family expanded to the
six lightning-powered Heroes featured in
the movies coinciding with the release
of the first film in 2019 DC launched a
new Shazam comic book written by Jeff
Johns it's a strange one not just for
its content but also because John's
seems to be constantly fighting with the
material and in the story of the Shazam
family's Journey Through the seven magic
lands whenever the fairy tale fun tries
to poke through it's interrupted by
actual or threatened dismemberment but
fairy tales can be plenty Grim too and
John's handles that balance best with
the fun lens and their ruler king kid at
first it's pure wish fulfillment in the
form of a world-sized theme park with
unlimited free rides and Candy the
Forever Young King has made it a Haven
for abused children but only as long as
they stay children his own history of
abuse has turned him against all adults
so as soon as his subjects turn 18
they're enslaved underground to keep The
Coasters rolling that includes Billy's
foster sister Mary and King kid quickly
turns on the rest of the family when
they reveal their adult supercells
foreign
[Music]